hey everyone how's it going my name's
may you go and welcome back to my
channel where we talk about tech career
and life I just woke up from a nap so
it's still kind of waking up slowly but
we're doing a Q&A video today I'm really
excited because community videos tend to
be really personal they're really fun I
get to talk about things that maybe
don't warrant an entire video or maybe
I'm not ready to make those videos yet
and so I went on Instagram and told
y'all to ask me anything and I got a lot
of responses so I'm excited to dive
right in
got my Kona in the back who's ready for
his afternoon nap so let's jump in and
before we dive into that I wanted to say
thank you to Skillshare for sponsoring
today's video Skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
inspiring classes or curious and
creative people you can explore new
skills deep in existing passions and get
lost in creativity I think it's
especially important during quarantine
times to explore and do some self-care
through creativity specifically I really
enjoy being creative and while I can do
that in code as a software engineer I
like doing that in other ways as well
it's one of my favorite ways to get in
touch with myself and do some self-care
and really understand how I'm feeling
through the medium of art one of the
classes that I really enjoyed taking on
Skillshare is called creative
breakthrough it exercises to power your
creativity confidence and career by
daniele cry so in this class you really
helps you to understand how to unlock
your creativity through these exercises
and I really found myself enjoying it
especially just as things have been
bundled up as we've been staying at home
for many months on it the first 1,000 of
my subscribers to click the link in the
description box down below will get a
two-month free trial of the premium
membership to explore your creativity
thank you so much to Skillshare for
sponsoring and now back to the video
what do you think you're going to miss
most
about the bay area that's a good
question I want to say it's like a combo
of the city San Francisco this city it's
someplace that I'll definitely miss it's
just so unique in its own way and I
think I'll miss going there and hanging
out with friends and kind of enjoying
like big-city life every once in a while
I'll actually miss being near SFO
because it's a lot easier to fly
directly to Japan from San Francisco
than it is from San Diego
definitely the Chinese food the nature
is also something Oh miss in the Bay
Area it's just unlike anywhere else I
think it's gorgeous and I think I'll
miss kind of the seasons too even though
San Francisco is still in California and
experienced the seasons very differently
from most other parts of the country
it's more seasoned hold in San Diego so
I'll definitely miss that and of course
our family and friends who are still
there but we're gonna visit often do I
ever get bored of coding and just get
frustrated yeah like all the time I
always kind of thought that because I
always found code to be boring and
frustrating like most of the time that I
didn't like coding itself but I realized
in the last few months that that's not
necessarily true
I do enjoy coding but yeah I can just
get really repetitive and monotonous at
times what is code if not a sequence of
instructions that get run over and over
and it's super repetitive right what
advice would I give to women of color
trying to get into engineering as well
oh good question
I haven't breached the topic of like
diversity in tech directly on the
channel diversity and inclusion is
something that I've always been really
passionate about in the tech industry
it's one of the reasons why I started
this channel but it's been really harder
to like talk about it like I've
definitely had my fair share of
microaggressions there
me or like being the only whatever in a
room like most often the only woman in
the room
so let me try answering this question so
I think the first thing is to educate
yourself on issues around diversity
equity and inclusion and technology and
I say as you get yourself on this topic
not because your experiences are invalid
but I think that learning about what's
happening at the broader scale makes all
of the daily stuff more manageable
because it can really be sad when you
like you find out that you're the only
woman and like an entire team or org or
you you know experienced some sort of
micro regression that like you know
doesn't get thrown to other people
because when certain events happen that
really are not nice you know when
there's bias somewhere you experience
yourself but you see other people
experience then I think understanding
the big picture of like why is this
happening and what are people doing to
solve it and what can you do to solve it
and play your role makes it feel a lot
more manageable and makes it feel like
you can make a change which it's true
like everybody has the ability to
influence and create change and so I
think doing that will give you kind of a
sense of hope hopefully and that's a
really important thing to hold on to
another thing that I often tell other
minorities in tech generally are to find
your community of people you might think
like oh but like what good does it do to
like talk to other people about this it
really does help actually I know that
when I'm going through something or
second-guessing myself having a group of
people who may or may not look like me
just people that I trust and know that
they have my back I can go to them and
they can lift me up and support me and
encourage me and help me feel seen and
heard and feel like I have a group of
people who can help me out through tough
times there are a lot of organizations
out there that cater to specific groups
of minorities in tech that kind of
provide this level of support but you
can also go to your friends your family
whoever you're comfortable talking to
I think it is really important to talk
about this and share experiences because
otherwise you're just gonna experience
all these paper cuts and next thing you
know everything's just gonna hurt and I
think talking to other people and
feeling that connection really heals the
body and also gives you hope next
question what I consider moving to Japan
in the future very good question I've
thought about this at multiple points
throughout my life the first time I
thought about it was when I was in high
school because I considered applying to
some Japanese universities in addition
to some American ones and then as I
started thinking about job prospects
towards the end of college that was also
another point in which I was like maybe
I should get a job in Japan both of
those times I decided not to mostly
because I thought the hurdle of
assimilating into a country and a system
that I'm really unfamiliar with was just
not really what I wanted to do at the
time but now that I'm an adult and
things are definitely different now
I don't really know the answer to this
question I probably wouldn't consider
living in Japan long term but I think I
do want to explore living in Japan for
like a couple of months well my parents
had me they actually thought that they
were gonna like go back to Japan and
raise me there and so I often think
about what my life would have been like
if they had made that decision and what
kind of person that would be in Japan
and I grew up in the United States and
spent most of my time here and so now
I'm like very American of my identity
with some like cultural wisps from Japan
I think it's still something that I'm
very curious about about exploring a
culture that kind of life could have
been a stronger part within me favorite
food places in San Diego wait okay I
have to think about this where are my
favorite food places in San Diego I'm
gonna write it down because I haven't
really like lived in San Diego for five
years I don't really know any of the new
places but these are some of like my
classic always go to places that have
been my favorites for a long time for
sandwiches
I recommend borden Bru for pizza I
recommend Pete support for coffee we
love going to Bird Rock coffee roasters
for Japanese food we really like Athan
and akong in convoy and then for
burritos it's a tie between Vitas elzar
Ave and senior grubbies which all serve
kind of look at different sort of
burrito oh and my favorite brewery I
think is Karl Strauss that's a hard one
to choose but I think that's my like
classic go-to right now but there's a
lot of good food in San Diego that I
stole and discovering and so that'll
probably this list will probably change
/b embellished over the next couple of
years but yes I think these are my
current favorites was I ever nervous
about posting to youtube because of my
employer this is a really good question
a lot of people who are thinking about
starting their own YouTube channels or
Instagram things often ask me this so I
posted my very first video while I was
working at patreon and yeah I was
definitely nervous mostly because it was
my very first video and within all the
shots that I got there was a lot of
people in the office who were part of
the video so I ended up going around to
everybody asking to make sure that they
were okay appearing in the video like
even if they were there for like a
quarter of a second I slashed them and I
was like hey you're gonna be in this
video is that okay and this is before I
even knew that this video was gonna blow
up and like do really well so yeah early
days at patreon I was definitely nervous
but then one more time I just got really
used to it like patreon is a company
made for creators and our CEO who is a
creator a lot of people in the office
were creators and so I wasn't really
that nervous ever about posting content
I definitely had conversations about
what's okay to post as an employee of
patreon versus what's not okay to post
and it was generally things like don't
post the source code of patreon online
because that we have competitors and
it's a start-up along with a couple of
other things like making sure that I
check
with anybody who was maybe accidentally
filmed or is gonna be part of my film
and making sure that I have their
approval to be in the video so yeah it
was a pretty easy set of guidelines to
follow there when I was at Netflix
however it was a little bit different
Netflix is a much much bigger company
and has a much bigger public image than
me or patreon basically so yeah again I
had lots of conversations with my
manager there I even talked to her
before I accepted the offered and make
sure that it was okay that I had a
YouTube channel and I kind of laid out
these are the things that I talked about
on the channel and I'm not gonna talk
about this set of things to kind of
respect the Netflix culture and code and
everything and stuff largely they were
pretty chill about it like I don't even
really like posting content that's
company specific anyways and if there
was like any ounce of the possibility of
talking directly about Netflix and I
talk to her sometimes I talk to PR folks
to make sure that things were gonna be
okay but one of the sessions that I made
for myself while I was working at
Netflix was that I didn't want people to
know that I was working at Netflix like
through my online presence number one
because I don't want to deal with all of
those like comments and DMS that are
like why can't you fix this in Netflix
app like why did this season get
cancelled cuz like that stuff is like
completely out of my control and also
because I didn't really want to like
intermingle like my brand with like the
Netflix brand and so that was something
that I decided that my manager was very
much on board with so yeah it was also a
pretty easy set of guidelines to follow
but I like being a rule follower and
like wanting to make sure that like
everyone is okay with what I'm doing I
did notice that I tend to post less
content both on YouTube and especially
on Instagram because I didn't really
want to like post things about what was
going on in the office or my day-to-day
stuff and so I think it kind of like
choked my creativity not because I think
the company did or my
team did but I think I did that to
myself because of the pressure of like
working at a really well-known company
and having a public image some people
deal with this way better than I did but
I just like really wanted to be like
completely in the clear at all times I
will say that there are certain
companies that I'd like really like have
never considered working at because
they're known for not allowing their
employees to have a public-facing image
or like give tech talks and stuff
because yeah like I always want to be
able to do my YouTube channel and be
able to talk about things openly and
honestly so yeah it's a it's a tricky
thing to navigate but I think like my
advice or anybody else who's in this
position is to like talk to your manager
and just like clear the air and address
any concerns and also just use like
common sense like don't disparage your
company or specific individuals at your
company yeah like just just common sense
where did Scott and I meet we met in
college we both went to UCSD and we're
part of the same engineering
organization we were friends for a year
before we started dating in my junior
year of college and we've been together
ever since
how is my experience as a youtuber
shaped my view of the tech industry so I
think there's two ways one is that I've
been able to meet so many more people in
the tech industry as a result of doing
YouTube I've been able to connect with
people who are in a completely different
country as me who speak different
languages as me who work in a very
different part of tech and have
conversations with everybody and that I
know would not have been possible if I
didn't create this channel so that's
kind of been really cool because I've
been able to make friendships with
people from all over the world kind of
feel the same feelings as me about tech
or we've had like really good
conversations around technology and life
in general and so that's kind of been a
blessing and I think that hat has a real
influence and how I view tech and just
my life and my work the second thing is
that because my content is really
towards like helping University students
or college bootcamp or prospective
software engineers into the industry I
think a lot about like why is it so hard
to get in as well as like just overall
themes and big-picture stuff about the
industry as a whole which like a lot of
people are thinking about I think most
software engineers like think about this
kind of stuff but it's forced me to
think in perspectives and really
consider problems in different ways and
not just like think about them but
figure out like what am I gonna do about
it and what kind of videos can I make
and also be able to look at like what
efforts have been done in the past that
may or may not have worked and what are
efforts that I can do that's like unique
to my audience my self medium that can
kind of be a part of all of that and
sometimes it's sad because like all I
find is like bad news about like what's
going on in the industry and how like
terrible it is I think that it's an
important perspective to have like to be
able to see it from that big picture
like high-level view before like diving
in and helping others and what's my
favorite tea I really like Japanese
tunes I think my favorite tea is
actually called Sebata which is
buckwheat tea it's decaf it's got like a
really nice nutty flavor
it's my grandparents favorite tea so I
really like that one in addition to
whole gego which is roasted green tea
and in the summers moody chat which is
barley tea but if you're asking for my
boba order it's usually a roasted along
tea with crema and boba that's my fave
oh also with 25% sugar and 50% icicles
like there's no way I can do 100% sugar
for boba like I will just bounce off the
walls its Kona the goodest boy planaria
the goodest boy are you the goodest boy
he's too sleepy all right that's it for
this video thank you so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed it make sure
to follow my Instagram where you can
like DM e questions kind of it anytime
and sometime
I host like a little mini AMA is in
there and don't forget to click
subscribe on this channel as well so you
don't miss any of my new videos coming
out I'll see you in the next one and
hope you have a great day wherever you
are
bye
[Music]